Hi I'm Linda Avey with 23andMe and I have
some information to share here on You Tube
which is great. We're here at the world economic
forum and one of the challenges we face within
23andMe and also a global problem is the patenting
of the human genome. And we're really interested
in hearing back from the community on thought
that how we can get around this problem or
creating almost like a quilt or a patch work
of ownership of the genome by companies and
institutions, universities. We just think
this untenable for the future. Especially
when we get to a point where we can sequence
the entire genome. How on earth is someone
going to get access to all of their information
if it's all a patch work. And people think
they claim an ownership of the genome. So
we would like to pose this question. And our
position is that we don't think that this
is right that some company or institution
can own a piece of your genome. It's ok for
them to make a drug against a piece of the
genome, or to innovate the genome, but simply
being able to read it and tell you what that
information means we think is just not the
wave of the future and is really gonna block
innovation in companies. So that's my challenge
to all of you. Thanks.